Okay.
Let's now go back to the delay of the election
idea that was floated months ago.
Joe Biden said that he believed Donald Trump
was going to try to create some kind of emergency
as a pretext to delay the election.
And a whole bunch of people said, oh, Joe
Biden's crazy.
Trump's not going to do that.
And then last week, Donald Trump floated the
idea on Twitter of delaying the election and
has since insisted at every opportunity that
this is going to be a rigged, phony election.
A top Democratic congressman in the House
now specifically says that Donald Trump is
going to use emergency powers to remain in
the White House if he loses the election.
So this idea is not about delaying the election.
It's about declaring an emergency.
If he loses to not vacate the White House.
Now, I'm talking here about House Majority
Whip Congressman James Clyburn.
This is probably the strongest reaction from
an actual federal lawmaker so far, saying
Trump's idea is to put a cloud over the election
and then use some kind of an emergency to
justify staying in the Oval Office.
Here is Congressman Clyburn himself on CNN
Sunday.
Do you really think Donald Trump is comparable
to Adolf Hitler?
What I said started at about two and a half,
maybe three years ago at every step of the
unions.
But I feel very strongly that this man has
taken on a strong arm tactics, and I feel
very strongly that she is Mussolini who is
Hitler.
I said that back then.
And I believe that I believe very strongly
this no idea about we want to peacefully transfer
power.
I don't think he plans to lead the White House.
You don't plan to say it, Alexis.
I believe that he plans to install himself
in some kind of emergency way to continue
to hold onto office.
And that's why the American people need to
wake up now.
You know, there are people who are not particularly
pleased with Clyburn, especially because he's
mentioning, you know, Mussolini and Hitler
in the same breath as Trump.
For me, what's lacking is a more detailed
explanation about how exactly Trump plans
to do it.
And so absent a specific plan, I still don't
see this as something that Donald Trump could
actually get away with.
But understand that this is a different idea
than delaying the election.
Delaying the election is what Trump floated
last week.
The idea here is Trump loses, but then uses
some kind of emergency declaration to try
to stay in power.
So a few different things.
No.
One, even Republicans are saying all of these
ideas are bogus.
Marco Rubio saying, you know, Trump can suggest
delaying the election, but that's not what's
going to happen.
I think that there's actually a point where
the the idea of of debating this is arguably
the problem.
And let me explain to you what I mean when
you bring on experts, politicians, whoever
to argue about can Trump delay the election?
Could he use an emergency to stay in power
or whatever?
You are legitimizing the idea of this as a
concept.
And what I mean by that is the real newsworthiness
of this story is the wildly authoritarian,
completely unhinged idea of delaying the election.
That's what needs to be reported on when you
bring in a member of Congress or a legal expert
and say, could Trump do this or how could
Trump do this, or is Trump doing this justified?
You are creating the notion that there's something
to debate here.
I do a bit of a different type of show than
what you see on corporate media.
So I've pointed out Trump can't really do
the states run their own elections.
You need at the federal level some kind of
decree from the House and Senate, which you're
not going to get.
But the focus of this story needs to be on
corporate media that Donald Trump is alluding
to something completely authoritarian and
dictatorial.
It is the idea of something that despot's
do and normalizing this idea of a delay or
staying in power.
Is almost saying it could be justified if
there is the debate as to whether Trump would
have the legal authority to do this.
It validates what should be a completely immediately
dismissed authoritarian idea.
That's my concern about some of these types
of segments.
So I'm curious to hear from you about that.
Let me know what you think.